Je pensais que nous allions entendre ta
mère faire du trampoline les
super-héros sont illégaux tu veux
combattre les méchants définit qui je suis
nous ne disons pas que tu as ce que quelqu'un
à la télé a dit j'ai été approché par ce
magnat dont les héros les plus parlés m'aident à
apporter  supers de retour au soleil
nous avons besoin d'Elastigirl
[Music]
deux enfants pas de problème
pas la façon dont tu es censé le faire papa
ils veulent que nous le fassions Je ne sais pas de cette
façon pourquoi changeraient-ils les mathématiques par rapport à
Düsseldorf, ce sont des chiens
Kyle c'est tellement lourd d'atropine
[Musique]
plus près Je n'aurais pas pu faire ça si tu
n'avais pas si bien pris le relais Je dois
réussir pour qu'elle puisse réussir
peut-elle l'obtenir Bob est délicat mais je ne peux pas
continuer à lui donner  cookies fait correctement la
parentalité est un acte héroïque fait correctement
vous
[Musique]
whosh way baby